please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded she'll be really should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the room by the
door to the fire escape staircase please
hold both handrails in case the stairs
are wet or slippery if anyone is unable
to use the stories of our others to exit
the room before they go to the fire
escape door where they can then be given
assistance our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic sweet please do not today your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return building until
given permission to do so by council
staff okay first item on the agenda is
apologies i have those your counselor
yah know do I have any other apologies
no you killed a non members attending I
don't see any millions of the meeting
held on 20 30 jun 2015 are they breathe
breathe breathe children under 13 wild
cash town council training it's to the
second federal that the bottle is
suggestions that town trash town council
be lost why they're not more engagement
is training this one
is that something we need to follow up
sounds different yes if we haven't had
the feedback we made forget it ever have
we said something out the parish's
generally we can we can check that and
if not make sure something is a minute
so it's going to be raised at the ball
coming parish summit and with Roger
tenant Association of local councils
Jeff if you look like getting bitten
touched with it the chair at the rotten
handed we're meeting next week we are in
to be haunted and gender either yeah
they are never level I am yes and my
don't recall to be fair at that specific
item being discussed that the rush 100
but i can mention it if you want me to
give you Dennis Lee having seems to be a
good idea and then zap it
so we go on to the main item 5 German
domain equation of interest okay so I
thought you know not so I do i do Papa
Joe any declarations of interest and
chair of the bottom Parish Council thank
you I'm chef Adam as a member of
raytheon Council or may have to share
interests as well give item 5 channel
any on me to do you want usual just
don't start up in last year and so yeah
oh yeah oh jong like it it's Thank You
chairman this is the the yearly member
Learning and Development Report the
first part summarizes training sessions
and related events including away days
and presentations from external partners
held during the 2015-16 municipal year
and and it also picks out where where
some lessons have been learned and
adjustments made to the training program
the report then goes on to identify some
self assessment feedback received and
suggestions for future courses it brings
out proposals for the introduction or
the induction of newly elected members
and the proposed training slots from may
to sep tember is for coming year as
usually wherever possible though the
program will be delivered by district
council officers and involve other
afternoon and evening sessions there's a
suggestion within the report that the
committee establishes a principle
whereby senior officers of the council
can join members at at their training
sessions where West such sessions are
to the officers development to the
officers own development and there's
also suggested in the report that it
could be practicable to establish a
minimum number of attendees that should
sign up in order for a bespoke planning
training course or session to be held
for parish or town councils the actual
recommendations are on page five point
one at report chairman members to go
through thank you see we won't make no
comments from Jim 5.6 of report my
apologies they check a couple of the
phone observations really we have a list
here of the district members that have
attended training the score card
expandable described a possible do
something for the parishes this of the
way so we know what courses they are
tending and not me so the parish members
but the parishes themselves as a
possibility and the other question I
wanted to ask was around the mandatory
training for the planning because the
planning committee has changed from all
members down to 13 with the possibility
of having substitutes if I was to ask
somebody to substitute for me how would
I know that they they qualify because
because obviously the substitutes the
other members need to have done the
training to be able to substitute for me
as a member of clarity didn't have to
give them notice of their attention
you back to some shoes then you'll
generally do we've we've always had them
phone us up and then we've checked our
figures at night I actually have a list
and then i'll give it to you saw me
because there's a plan you can shield
shall know who done it the professor yes
german that will be a need for a list of
members that have attended the training
that could act as substitutes and only
they could act as substitutes that's so
come back on the jet so what is the best
procedure for a member of the plan
committee to look for substitute and do
they go to the member first or should
they go through committee attention to
find out who they can ask what's the
best way of working or in each of the
busy send committee section be asked to
arrange please or something yes for all
how's that work I think it would be for
the member to approach a substitute if
they know who's had training than the
know who to approach or they could
communicate with you know with the
committee section if they weren't sure
about that to find out before making
that approach German so the busy center
would hold on yes we'd we'd hold a list
of who'd have the training German on the
call is what made chairman on the
question of rec hall or perish
attendance at to training being part of
report that that is something for the
committee it's not being something this
felt and needful previously but that
would be a matter for the you know for
the particular committee i believe all
just you know the sort of work to
establish it but it I guess it's where
the committee feels there's a value in
that
the allowed sale naturally yes I just
remind members from the parish council
point of view yes its association of
local council also provides training
some of which thus sort of shadow watch
who you're serving students so you know
it doesn't necessarily mean that parish
councillors aren't getting training
which is going elsewhere we're going to
download to get it ok any other comment
if I come back ok really nice my idea
was that we have some sort of indication
of what sort of training the parishes
are doing whether it's outside or with
us and then we lookin you know see are
we offering the right things result
that's really what my thoughts on that
which applies also falls to district
council devices yeah I might I think
well I know quite honestly that some of
the course this offered sort of
safeguarding and and also homelessness
I'm really relevant to our to consider
perhaps by the members of the smaller
parish councils particularly relevant to
their responsibilities for all the
actual makeup of parish which is why
they learn are not responding did get a
very good feedback from the line
the last mandatory and the last man to
be planning session um that's it I
didn't go I just know it was a planning
what I'm sure I think there was a
special one just for hello write it yeah
I did recall seeing any parish members
of the know what is soo little
relatively secular full council that
they'd been to planning couple of them
at bay india and i found it very useful
what the edging a caiman I don't know
yeah yeah obviously obviously not the
planning session i was i was thinking up
for that okay
this well as we've gone on to mandatory
claim I would like to speak about magic
reclaim sessions firstly I think we were
aware that the last mandatory planning
session and are though that there's now
the committee's being severely reduced
to 13 that the majority of members do it
eight because of the substitution and I
think that is probably something that
you have to see in the future hope it is
because planning is an important part of
the role of district councillor but the
mandatory planning sessions sister being
increased to for a year have been
somewhat lacking perhaps in the
appropriateness the roles of district
council the idea of a training session
is to educate us and the education
should be appropriate and it should
assist us and two of the mandatory
planning sessions and I'm sure that
other members able to worry including
the last one unfortunately were pure
speculation there was nothing that I
remember sitting and there was a very
interesting discussion about mr. pickles
put possibly intentions but anyone could
read the press in fact I need more
romantic than what was mentioned in that
meeting and it was a waste of everyones
two rounds we had a similar situation
with the last training session I think
they eat my vocal that cross-party and
Daris April's party members were
dissatisfied ritually say severely with
the content of the training now I don't
want to criticize the obvious because I
think we have a problem and the problem
is one that we've actually created what
we have if we have a planning department
that is under severe civilian staffed
and under severe strain we are asked in
the narrative for commander
twice a day so that's eight effectively
today we're taking a huge number of star
away from the wrong and those sessions I
think because of the number of sessions
they're no longer give us the value of
the training that we need so I think we
should look again that the number of
sessions of mandatory planning training
the two reasons there is no point in us
saying we need four sessions if those
sessions aren't going to have the
quality of educating appropriately and
assisting the members in their roles and
to my mind the planning training in the
past has always been very good and I'm
sorry to say that those two sessions and
the more ease that such as haven't
perhaps being as good and I think we're
asking too much of our offices and I
think there's a dual problem there and
from our point of view if we're offering
training it should be appropriate and
that joking aside I think we all know
the couple of sessions that were so is
it was that a temperate situationally
increased a fall as i understand it was
a trial that trivers now presumably
concluded should we not be looking to
see whether or not we continue with the
for mandatory we're assume to or we go
for compromise of the throne but I
certainly don't think that we need to
carry on with the training that we're
getting at the moment yeah I think it's
helpful I think in the past we we had
for planning training sessions Bologna
two of them the mandatory maybe had
surgery Rahman shall surely any head
spinning yeah you too mainstream over I
just had a fever I didn't think my
recollection is not the same facts mr.
Bostock can clarify that point but
either way whether they're mandatory or
not he's putting Australian the officers
and they're not really it's putting a
sturdy splitting Australian counselors
as well certainly we found it
exceedingly difficult from to have to
catch the roundness at short notice
because the training takes work attire
daughter we always attend in the
afternoons the last two occasions are
very short notice that stopped so is
causing problems what rather than knew
who I think we have to assemble problems
are there and look how we're going to
resolve those problems rather than try
and gloss over them and pretend they're
not there they are there but we need to
be positive and resolved so hoping
someone's got some suggestions and how
we can you comment on the job
I mean I think the current situation is
along the lines of there are four set
per year and the need to not miss more
than one of them in terms of the
potential impact on the officer resource
and perhaps what what could be done
around that that is something that the
committee to consider your terms of
reference are determining the annual
member training program I mean if it's
something that members feel should be
looked at fairly promptly then
potentially officers could work in
consultation with the chairman of this
committee in fat exploring a solution
for the near future and then review it
again when the committee you know meets
formally for instance that's one of the
sort of comments you know members will
be non planning the district members
here and they they've got to feel for
you know that that's that's what I say
around around those things really I'm
sure you know just I just wanted to try
to fight and because they mentioned that
there's four meetings does that include
the initial meeting for new counselors
now and feeling I wasn't a comment when
your boys is all this time the same
partner question is that is that a new
induction meaty
mandatory for all councils so as I made
you the new transfers this this for
mandatory meetings a year for people
that want to maintain their activity on
the planning it comes back to the
question you asked about subbing you
can't miss 12 consecutive meetings that
you can miss alternate months so you
only have to attend to well that defeats
objective if someone's playing the game
of only going to to when they could go
to point that the meetings were good and
the education was there then we all
should be attending but I I know that
the strain and officer time isn't really
part of our remit but I do think it's
it's something that we should be aware
of but certainly we should be away with
the quality and the appropriateness of
the training sessions and that is
something that I think we need to look
at you get the other side of the coin of
course is that planning or is changing
very rapidly chairman this meeting could
certainly minute that it would like the
quality and the nature of the training
looked at it it could I mean the
suggestion was made of the number three
I mean that the intent of the council up
to this point and this committee has
been before to allow for may be wantin
to be missed maybe maybe maybe looking
at three might be why for just just
thinking in terms of practicalities away
for Nancy hell you know it's see how it
looks after that but soon as a call that
you could you know from here obviously
could go away and look at that quality
issue if they've members it yeah an
unpaid assistant director of planning
for planning made any expressed any
views on this
well it would be I mean in terms of in
terms of of what training might be right
and whether or not that could be
improved it's something that would want
to consult the assistant director on and
that you know if that's the committee to
view then then that would be the right
the right thing to do and there may be
something from that that could come to
it you know to set each a meeting I mean
up another possibility would be to take
away the aspect of the quality and
thinking around possibilities and then
these things as they are are at the
moment subjective looking at that with
the full report to the next you know
standards committee in the new municipal
year there's another in a possibility so
it doesn't push it to inhibit just
distorts I think bear in mind the
feedback into going to see something
that we should mr. as you say there's
two issues one is quality and one is
quantity and I've personally feel they
have an impact on each other and I think
if we were to reduce it correctly mr.
chairman but it wasn't meant to be a
charm wasn't it listen with these four
sessions for mandatory sessions no I
don't think was relatively recently the
before was intended to be a trial or
contemplated and being a troll but i
think the dropping of the afternoon
session was was to be a trial my
recollection when it's a really read
recollection is that there was as been
for quite a long time amanda to planning
training there was a point where not all
men was around to get make it a
particular one and there was mop up
sessions and that became practicably an
issue for the members and the offices so
the concept developed for over the year
here with a sort of miss one in your
perhaps out sort of approach than that
not as a trial that as a you know as it
has a as the arrangement do you think
you can actually miss two sessions
aren't you is also not consecutive yes
because permutations and combinations of
us good night which as I say almost
makes an operative it's only if we were
to consider having three and have that
same rule in place not two consecutive
it would have the same impact but I
hopefully because the offices would have
a slightly longer period of time between
planning training sessions they could
perhaps find more the problem with that
of course is that the member could
validly attend just one mandatory
planning session now the good news is
the 32 consecutive first and the third
hasn't first in the third just yesterday
yeah yes that happened if that happens
in you but I think that was the problem
ventures I mean this way at least you
you have to attend to ban association
yes but as we were away this training
and this panic session and they should
be training yes and that I think is the
fundamental point that it comes down to
you it's our way boom fingers gym
without a doubt the any training we
haven't got to be over a sufficient
quality in context for us to job meant
as a do the job that we were to do on
the development committee both as
members in and substitute so I think
that should be looked at as a separate
thing the number of the training
sessions i think i would like to go down
to 23 simply because the the the two
consecutive the attendees that you've
got attendance you've got to have which
will make it more difficult I think for
some members to attend to in two
consecutive
training sessions if there's only the
three so one like to see that reduced
because obviously to out before I think
is important Jessica our clients with
layers of the last time the end it
before is better because particularly
for members away and holiday during the
session comes out of people to know
sometimes my apologies around these
enjoy I thought you thinking aloud here
of this country is this something that
perhaps the review committee should be
considering or is it for us to perhaps
get the assistant director to come in
and talk to us with regards to the
training was just wondering what a best
way to determine its within this
committees term of reference terms of
reference of determine the annual member
training program I am I just just added
thinking in terms of the report this
last year has seen one or two approaches
where for instance has maybe been a bit
of training before a development
committee and all there hasn't been an
afternoon and an evening session now
suggestion in this paper is that that
that gets removed and that the current
policy remains which is that there's
four sessions after in an evening
however you know this committee could
adjust that that's that that's four
members it wouldn't be a review
committee matter unless the review
committee will deter to it but it is
this committee terms of reference
chairman Sir yeah
I must admit I had a little bit of a
concern about the the real training
sessions before the planning committee
meeting watching themselves I found them
very valuable I was a bit concerned that
the members of the public might see that
in slightly different offices that are
we discussing about the planning
applications that are coming forward a
bit of a concern about that all of that
didn't happen and what happened I'm sure
but I think perhaps that could be missin
70th be removed 10 so that they don't
happen anymore change that so come on
perhaps inject my proposal that we talk
to the new assistant director for
planning the next standards committee
meetings in our back with some sorts of
ideas or having an improvement over the
training but I think we need to involve
the assistant director in that inner
process although I don't think I'm right
in saying that the actual content of the
training session is not within our
roommate is that right apart familiar
general said in a general sense yeah the
only thing that if I'm a chairman this
week we're heading to a new municipal
year it's important that the development
committee that will be in place for
manual council can operate and in that
context you may not have I mean it's
combinations and permutations again
maybe but you may not have it if there
is a different assistant director
planning they might not be in place in
time for but it could be that the
committee could as soon as practicable
get advice from bad officer and and
consider the issue again in the new
musical users
interstate at the status quo yes he'll
building out the comment that the
quality I'm getting a sense that that is
quality and content if you're mindful of
you might a lot the appropriate this up
of your mindful or well you know would
that make with general approval
everything so we keep it with the fall
mr. chairman before trains yes viewing
it you're next in the next to enjoy this
beautiful year yes Caroline boss we're
on training sessions mr. chairman you
mentioned afternoon and evening which
has been the normal side with some
sessions obviously with outside France
factory and have myself but I noticed
that member suggestions have they said
the option of morning sessions would be
useful and certainly I think anyone in
education knows that people tend to
absorb and learn new information better
the earlier another day the 60 meters of
course but I wonder if it's possible for
us to actually not now because we were
going to have a new year but post may
the fifth us the new counselors if they
prefer morning afternoon or evening so
that if we are offering two sessions we
can offer them to suit the majority
rather than just say we're doing
afternoon evening or we do morning and
evening
we do they time because the moment most
of our members are available in daytime
it may be that they would prefer daytime
meetings it may not be I don't know but
I think it's a very simple thing that
this committee could do weekly to ask
the members or they would prefer and
then try and provide the sessions to
meet their needs the majority but my
concern on that just a profit on my head
is that as far as the visor officers are
concerned the morning maybe a
particularly busy time and I think I'm
right in saying that the afternoon and
evening sessions have been the case was
that for as long as I can remember and
he seems to work fairly well and being
generally where accepted but don't know
they've never tried an intensive no no
one of the views of the other members
Jeremy speaking from a personal point of
view as a work full-time mornings would
be far more difficult for me than I've
known for and I tend to look for the
evening training rather than the day
time period because of work commitments
and we honestly don't know
of what the intake of the new counselors
will be what they mix well that will be
so i think i think it's perhaps getting
something we need to consider matron i
must say my Conisbrough largely thought
about by my recollection of my working
days before I retired when the morning
was always a very busy time
the phone would ring in the there's a
correspondence to be dealt with
immediately and generally speaking if
one had to get away in the afternoon the
afternoon was much much easier to to do
I did say as part of the house I would
suggest that it was for the new
committee to look at and I think it's an
engine should be casual and I can accept
your comments I think however when I was
at work that the mornings would have
been better for me we all have different
working for calls you and I think we
have to which is my idea that post made
fifth that just a sort of simple inquiry
goes out so every new every member who
will all be new members at that time of
one sort or another even if it's and
just a refresh and just ask them what
they would prefer at least then we would
have that information before us at the
next meeting it doesn't mean that we
would have to go with it but we would
have been acting on information rather
than supposition the other thing I was
going to I certainly from my business
point of view is a mighty training from
the Ministry things now he is now 1 done
online now whether that's something we
perhaps need to consider as
coming more computerized other than just
because lots of that connection will do
it that's the only way for mot test is
now for example to be able to get
training that they have to simply then
at the end of that really over a given
amount of time and it can be monitored
so maybe that's something you might want
to consider as one or other than well it
should be another option yes how do we
go I'm sure we could have it all all
possible options but like I think you
have the imminent election we don't know
what they yes make up a committee is
going to be our from a fit so I think we
can really just mount these ideas and
then they might throw them in for
consideration after my third time on
chair not just add value if we did offer
something on the internet that's one
thing it might be easier for your plan
for the parrises to be able to get more
involvement we thinking you have to do
it that's why I don't have to stir crazy
thorgan I think one has to bear in mind
they're killing each rainy you don't
actually know where the person's done to
trading would not well I can only
compare it to the DNA tested me know
right okay I got it comparing to the
industry they seem to be quite happy
with it
for a mighty trainings yeah mr. Chairman
I could just come back from that I
appreciate that the council may left or
will be changing to some extent after
the fifth of man but we have elections
three years out of four and it kills we
shouldn't be more about in what it's
doing because as the election we should
be going forward and we should be
proactive well is why I'm suggesting
that we get the information so that the
new committee whatever the composition
is it can make decisions on the other
maybe we're leaving it Nessa we have
very few meetings if we leave it to the
next meeting then they have to ask for
that that thing we've learned and
flossed almost reunion I you
misunderstand I'm all in favor of
getting the information out but I made
me really referring to no let no project
I've made referring to making any
decisions I think we could Bob by all
means I've look I don't see any reason
why we shouldn't gather to get some
information that I was just a little bit
consider their face push it touched
Merlin there goes along lass thank you
thank you mr. Chen mr. Chen can i maybe
come in regards to the alone and sister
mentioned before about the e-learning
and I'm used to alerting for instance
come on in my professional life and it
is recorded and everybody knows exactly
what training everybody is done and the
generally there is a test afterwards to
test understanding which i think is
important particularly regards to
planning so everybody knows that people
do understand what is required to them
in from a plan accordingly yes not very
cool there are some really good programs
out there but having the deputy with
that
it wouldn't be suitable from them yeah
it's something that people could do in
your own time as well you know when it's
convenient yep basis they wish to it I
think it's just another avenue that we
could include and you know for those
from the parish point of view that they
might be able to dovetail into that in
an easier way perhaps so they look this
involve for example an officer of
recording Lee the training and then say
then the no no alerting usually you get
little slice or scenarios and you're
you're invited to click if you like lon
should they do anything I will say oh I
say so you it's done in stylized form
and there's lots of different ways of
doing it you kind of have videos that
you cannot ask questions on but the most
common way that you'll agree is a
stylized sort of questionnaire thing and
perhaps if you click on that bubble you
might get no you pick the wrong one up
and then you score as you go along and
at the end you know if you've passed or
failed but sometimes it's feedback
sometimes for questions the scored as
you go along sometimes and understanding
analysis at the end there's lots of
different ways of approaching reason it
is they are very good show you the
questions about not a choice on yes you
say if that proved to be a popular
notion it may be something for example
where we could have two mandatory
prepare planning training sessions in
the traditional working and to be
learning I don't think we could do that
because as I've said not all members
would be able to access I mean I
couldn't access for my time I can't
access any I have enough told getting
emails when a hell it burned email for
Essex County Council on Monday but
apparently I hadn't
but sometimes my emails they reach most
certainly attachment so it's nothing to
do with the equipment migori is the
internet structure and until that is
resolved and lots of other people will
have the same problem that is not going
to be a possibility because then you're
asking CalSTRS to come to another venue
in critically subjective it's not
helpful I don't think it should be no I
think it should be considered as an
addition so that you can go to perhaps a
mandatory training or doing we need to
consider it fooling i mean it's it's a
brilliant home unfortunately not
everyone on the able to access it and
there's also some people might have
problems with their eyesight there might
have been to use it so we couldn't make
that part of a mandatory and training
session but we study could offer it as
perhaps an alternative yes alternative
computer is like at libraries I'm surely
would make facility available here at
the somebody to pop into but having done
being personally having done a lot of
this e-learning I think it's more
productive because you can turn up to a
session you can sit there and be talked
to for a couple of hours those off come
back again and go home and how much have
you actually taken in whereas with you
learning who say that you have to your
questions either right or wrong you know
you read it or whatever and then you
have to demonstrate your understanding
of it and at the end is Christine says
you'll get a score and quite often get
us a difficult as well to go with it so
you have to actually pay attention so I
things much much you've ways okay I
think it's an optional we need to
explore yeah
he didn't jump routes the officers could
have a look at perhaps book because we
know places like the local government
love common sociation do have elearning
facilities we know it sometimes done for
officers taking on board dirt it's about
equality and maybe for mandatory it
might not be but but if it just going to
explore introducing an e-learning
situation as part of member training
program and come back on that very
useful bearing in mind that the other
comments that we made the rounded the
level playing field thing and me and the
ease of access and model members have
got the same facilities or it will them
i'll be your health for other reasons
alone for those eyes he remembers to
travel that's costing the case it is
unproductive again i think it's a
brilliant option and i think it's
something that we should as you say
explore but i would be very very
concerned to see as a mandatory issue
thank you can build that into looking
like the other things you know into the
next musical year ready for the next
report you know such world are deers are
thought to us I mean it well nothing
wrong a wild i will put wild in a minute
story yes again hello what we will see
various mate
not quite as a question on item 2 12
membersin I understand that there was a
condition katana boo that at least one
of these courses that when the member
came back that he gave presentation what
he learned to counsel it was that
condition for boom yes thank you can I
ask a question around each other
attendance at meeting I don't I don't
know the answer to this which is why I'm
asking is there any way that if members
are recommended to attend certain
training as part of a standards issue
could be standard straining it could be
any other training clue if members are
recommended to do that as part of a
standards issue is there any way for us
a standards committee to know anonymized
of course that that has actually taken
place
sure question did you mean if the
monitor not management systems what if
the if the monitoring officer has
recommended all right as hard for
standards complaint yes oh I get it
that's a member should for example
attends the next been off about a lot of
standards training or it could be
development training or could be appeals
train or whatever whatever the issue is
is there any way of this committee
knowing that that those members have
attended the recommended training which
would have to be anonymised of course
but just as a statistic just just sort
of you may close the game her of x yeah
it was asked to attend training abs z
and this answer yes doing I don't know
if I monitoring the whole standards
issues I think the result is a monitor
up one fan officer would monitor with
this committee even know that that
condition have been placed upon that
with this committee need to know exactly
I think he's I mean I know we at that
devil opinion the monitoring officer
would be dealing with it I just wondered
because yes independent purses that's
part of our role is that we discuss and
recommend don't we with the monitoring
officer in some cases and I just
wondered that's off my head whether
there was any mechanism for us as a
committee to know that those
recommendations had been carried out
because it's about increasing the
competencies as of the of the members in
it and I don't it was a full
it's not stand to be corrected and
here's a full mechanism for that I
didn't think it was because we've not
had it presumably this is something that
the monitor monitoring monitoring
officer would liaise with the relevant
independent member that is to say the
independent member that the monitoring
officer has consulted in connection with
that particular complaint and would
liaise mother coming that doesn't happen
I was just it was just ya know I just
wondered as a way of of monitoring the
development of members that have have
had recommendations made that's all hmm
that makes it what chu qu chairman of
just maybe commented obviously there are
occasions when a monitoring issue would
get as far as a subcommittee of this
committee and I only thought tonight if
Here I am again we're looking at a
training report which is important but
not the standards matter however the
monitoring officer where they reached
the point in the case where they need to
consult an independent member would have
their own mechanism for keeping tabs on
and and going back to the independent
member if if there was an issue around
and I think you know that that that
that's the way we would normally be it
it's also I suppose a question of what
value the committee would place on
having I mean this committee I know you
used to have lots of information about
all sorts of things and and it's it's
about what what's felt useful I'm not
saying it isn't but it's just you know
it's not a straightforward things that
make sense I was just something that
occurred hasn't verified originally if
somebody
creature one of the procedures and then
wanting to an officer was totally they
went to an independent amendment and
made a decision whether that person
should be spoken to if it could be
resolved generally it was and that was
the end of the matter if it got more
serious where we've only had about six
on nearly ten more years then came to
the Sun committee who decided what to do
but out of those I can only be called to
that it went any further reported back
and never had what happened it was
assumed that it was solved in the last
couple of years I've got approached
twice the end result to them I am
unaware of him yes absolutely not want
superior god help I am unaware of and I
believe that at the end of the year and
maybe a little report said over the last
year these are two breaches have been
dealt with and that's the end of it I
feel that was the case I don't think
this child no no no so yeah so that
monitoring officer it would be the only
one who know whether your person went
through the proper training or whatever
happened
the time alakazoom is the emulsion
offices responsibility to ensure that
that is in fact carrying out yes it is
that case move to the recommendations
when I taken individually the first
recommendation is there the committee
resolves to receive the summary of
members of attendance at training
sessions during the municipal year
2015-16 SS housing power got to one is
that agreed secondly to endorse the
proposals for the member learning and
development program for 2016-17 as set
out in paragraphs for 12 4 10's at
afraid German will be adding the
observations around the development
committee training be learning and one
that's while the masses just just around
our area I'm thinking so as a landed
violet by that yeah that agreed agreed
agreed thirdly that it would be agreed
in principle that where appropriate
senior officers be invited to join
members in attending certain training
sessions where this training has been
requested in the course of a star
appraisals that agreed
and finally that a minimum number of
attendees be established for planning
training sessions organized by parish or
town councils one point of local
language yup do we need to establish
what the minimum number should be what
is that when you have it really was that
in purple it it would be a matter for
thee for the committee and it might be
useful guidance but for officers are
it's it's here on the basis of the
paragraph at the top of page 5.6 where
the last training session run by the
assistant director planning for there
were four attendees a it is for the
committee if it has a view it might it
might think or perhaps there should be
seven fifty percent of the parish and
town councils or something else but the
officers haven't got made a
recommendation on that but it has just
raised is raised his head yeah any views
on that it was difficult for us to set a
number because obviously there is a cost
for a training session let's say that
cost is 300 pounds if 15 members
attained then the cost is obviously kind
of
have you set the cost as you set the
number of gates the cost of it how we
can do that it was probably vary
depending on with you know because you
didn't I guess if it's an outside person
coming into the training an object
hospital be higher so you need more I
think decides it needs to be cost
effective I don't know I don't know how
we can just let them I mean to German
this is training offered on council
accommodation by the assistant director
planning and all their their staff in
terms of cost i guess it's officer time
which has had a bit of an airing early
your I'm just observing that but it
members you know i mean the the trains
are free of charge for each of the
parish and town councils it's just
whether the committee had a view on a
number or it can leave it that there
isn't of you and that if there's two and
then it's held or yeah it wasn't an
officer
to have a procedure to establish another
here as nothing mr. chair we need to
have a view that's what we're here for
what that for you is what one optimizer
poses a week was simply leave it to the
discretion new assistant director but
when you want to to do that or to
reserve it to this committee no I'm
sorry mr. general i think that the
committee should take the decisions that
is good i don't think we should be
delegating too much to start and I think
it's fair and I don't think its nine
ways is delegated practicalities wrong
yes but having said that it's difficult
one I don't think I understand the
cost-effectiveness argument but I think
when we're training parish town councils
the cost-effectiveness practicing the
only objective the objective is to raise
the standard of education going to go
back to that chestnut month right so I
don't think the cost effectiveness is a
role we couldn't but if we've got 14
parishes I would expect if half of them
aren't attending then perhaps we ought
to be questioning why not and where we
were offering this and I would have
expected perhaps us to be inundated not
four out of 14 perishing but most
parodies have an average of I don't know
attend summer 16 some are much smaller I
know but you know if you take an average
of tell you what 140 people you've not
got ten percent coming so perhaps what
you see I don't and when it's only the
first place that is free of charge for
each parish but that's still 14 pages so
you've got a full changes taking of
reproaching free food prices which
either sister training is not
appropriate on I don't know what it says
but there's a properly there's a problem
if you've got four people attending
potential 14 great places
salam there you go but there is there is
an issue issue quite amazingly the
ruptured hundred hope the verification
played back from a group meeting at the
moment I wouldn't know how to resolve
that that little detail is to the wire
people are attending as we're going to
do a little bit of a survey of the
parishes and ultra confidence religion
as I eat that back as well there that's
as to why they're not sticking I can
explain why I perylene violet Irishman
is here Sadie you know I want to comment
on it and it will be easy to say there
must be a minimum of fifty percent of
the total number of parishes in which
affected me a 70 effectively but whether
that will actually work out to be right
or not any time you feel I think
somewhere we've got to go to yardstick
that perhaps we can hear back from the
parachute and then yeah that's another
thing become just a thought chairman you
consult parishes there's no restriction
from what I can tell them when that
trainings held you in the year have a
report back to this committee so that
you can make a more informed decision
based on what's being discussed then
thank you John nice day just a pure time
you we don't know well that's yeah I've
been on Christmas Day German feeling and
a clever will do they and of course a
cost because they get one the one place
free don't think that any other they
have to pay the 40 the full Japan yes
but you've got at least ten they wear to
work oakley but 11 free prices that
weren't taken advantage of so there's
something fundamentally wrong these is
rare for people who have an interest not
to want to take parts and to learn more
about the interest i would I mean yes
then you know what that is not a problem
well this is a discussion in going round
round round while parish is attending
development sessions a years we never
come to any conclusion because we never
get an answer o people don't want to
come then have and you have I don't know
how our parishes functionable I know how
they are planning mittee functions
wrestlin have been on it a long time
it's their interest and updating on they
get updated enough by the car to carry
on year after year after year I don't
know you know they just knows it you can
take horse to water but you can't make
it drink that I please there's a social
times in the last few years I'd rather
thing that's probably the bottom line
but it would be interesting to say for
watchful hundred and sort of bring it
home a bit more the importance yeah as
long as the sessions are relevant to the
life of that particular parrot
if we can do there perhaps it's just
another you thought and I'm side of it
just a thought thing like parish Clark's
an option at some point could be
something for parish Clark so then they
trickle through to their you know
council that you to thought and we
haven't all out on on the paper so it
seemed quite the parish clerks or was it
just know it can't be lots you can be
felt in the free face either or boy I
just a thought well perhaps I can be 32
as Roland so only things that particular
what Magnus I think that that we can
still proceed with that I think it was
be proposes that committee resolves
there's a minimum number of attendees be
established for planning training
sessions organized town councils ever
say that it be determined to that it be
established so we are making efforts to
rent increases information stop you two
into neighbors to establish you
naturally they're being pretty sore
subject to yes we are establishing than
it should be and then we just don't know
what it is indeed so I think and it
might be matter matter of semantics but
fan I think we can sit leave it as it is
unless you particularly want to insert
the words in principle yeah but I think
as it as it stands it as it stands
chairman you could have a report back in
the new municipal year to this committee
how the outcome of some explorer
exploratory questions for the decision
to be to be made then let that be fine
Jim yeah that helps so that we can carry
that proposal it down to just a wee what
you're looking into it you're looking
into that
India you know you're looking at the
next training session for the parachute
doesn't need to be until after this
committees reached more of a decision on
it okay that makes sense if that's if
that's what them so are you saying that
the item for can't stand as it is yeah
we are still allowing for further
investigation to determine the actual
yet remain remember yes yes good right
so the recommendation I won't repeat it
once more is that agreed thank you there
being no other business may I take this
opportunity to thank everyone for their
tenders this computer civil year and god
willing we might even be back next week
and